desjardins hommes le stratège
macroéconomique jimmy jean au poste de
vice président et économiste en chef et
stratège de l'institution il est la
première personne issue de la diversité
à tenir ce rôle au sein de l'institution
financière la plus importante au québec
avec 7 millions cinq cent mille clients
près de cinquante mille employés
il succède à françois dupuis qui prend
sa retraite après prendre trois ans chez
desjardins
bonsoir jimmy jean soir
félicitations d'abord et avant tout
comment vous accueillez cette nomination
mais merci beaucoup de moi je
l'accueille avec énormément d'humilité
mentionné desjardins la plus grande
institution financière au québec la plus
grande coopérative financière au canada
alors d'arriver à ce stade dans une
institution d'envergure aussi important
que desjardins s'appelle choix que
d'être un moment très très particulier
mais en même temps très content et
jettera de relever les nombreux défis
qui se posent devant nous dans la
poursuite de cette reprise économique
est ce qu'il est ce que ça représente
quelque chose de particulier pour vous
qu'une grande institution comme
desjardins choisissent aussi une
personne qui est issu de la diversité
pour ce poste tout à fait je pense que
c'est
c'est un sujet dont on a parlé
abondamment dans les terriers parti n'a
la dernière année mais même un
auparavant donc d'avoir des gens issus
des milieux de la diversité de la
diversité au québec à des dépenses comme
ça c'est extrêmement gratifiant et moi
je suis très fier aujourd'hui de
représenter ce mouvement là je suis je
suis pas le premier dans les
institutions financières au canada et
j'ai l'impression que je serai pas le
dernier
alors
je suis là pour montrer aussi aux gens
qui sont issus de bagages de la
diversité que c'est possible qu'on y
mette du travail et que les gens croient
en nous est-ce que des objectifs
particuliers qui viennent avec la
nomination aujourd'hui jimmy jean
l'objectif c'est clairement qu'on est un
économiste travaillant un économiste
c'est dans les périodes de crise
on travaille le plus fort parce que
l'économiste notre métier c'est de ceux
souvent de trouver des réponses aussi
dans les crises que les demandes de
réponse que l'incertitude la plus élevée
donc les demandes pour avoir des
réponses est la plus grande donc oui il
ya des objectifs est effectivement de
d'éclairer nos membres et clients dans
cette atteinte de demeures compréhension
d'être capable de mieux situer la
conjoncture commencent à 6 prochain
cycle va se dessiner va se dérouler et
des enjeux très près particulier très
propre à la crise que nous venons de vie
donc c'est une crise qui complètement
atypique et cette reprise là va être
également à typer donc moi je peux pas
dire qu'ils aient un meilleur temps 1h
situation où un meilleur contexte pour
un économiste de vrai qu'actuellement
étant donné les défis intellectuels qui
a pour effet de comprendre ce nouvel
environnement
et là est ce que vous voyez une forte
reprise économique d'ici la fin de
l'année nous avons une très forte
reprise économique déjà on a vu avec des
données du premier trimestre par exemple
au canada on a eu 6,6 pour cent de
croissance annualisé à terme
préliminaire mais il reste que si ça se
confirme ce serait plus fort que les
états unis ont connu et malgré le fait
que les états unis ont pas connu les les
confinements qu'on a eus
particulièrement en ontario et aussi au
québec au premier trimestre donc ça
augure bien pour la suite on est en
troisième vague oui mais on a vu
l'économie a démontré sa résilience
donc nous on s'attend à une croissance
cette année au canada de 6,3 pour ça et
aux états unis on est onze heures
presque 7%
les des chiffres qui sont d'ampleur que
les thèmes six mois ces chiffres pour
les économies comme la chine pour l'un
on part
le pays développés donc très forte
croissance mais c'est aussi un rebond
une récupération après une très forte
contraction qu'on a connue en 2020 et
après ça la suite des choses en 2021 en
2022 plutôt ça va être de voir à quelle
vitesse on est capable de récupérer au
niveau des emplois dans les secteurs qui
sont plus touchés que ou est ce qu'on
risque de voir une économie qui va être
différent une demande qui va être
différent par rapport à ce qu'on
connaissait avant cette année avec une
hausse des taux possiblement 2022
une hausse des taux possiblement la
banque du canada déjà donné le signal
ses imposants qu'elle va nécessairement
aussi en 2012 mais son signal stipule
clairement que la fenêtre va commencer à
s'ouvrir à partir de la deuxième moitié
donc nous on s'attend à ce que la banque
du canada à ce sujet cela aux environs
de d'octobre octobre 2022 hockey et ce
qui est intéressant aussi c'est que du
côté des états unis la réserve fédérale
on a un discours qui actuellement est
tout autre c'est à dire que on nous dit
que aux dernières nouvelles tout dans
l'horizon qui s'étend jusqu'à la fin
2023 au le scénario américain est encore
plus positif plus favorable pour une
vaccination qui est plus avancé dans
l'est aussi de stimulation budgétaire
qui est plus fort ok on va avoir la
chance d'en parler souvent ensemble une
fois de plus félicitations jimmy jean
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup je me fais
plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne i see
her dit
oh